翻訳: Haruko NAGAI
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
僕の行っている
ライフセービングの目指すものは
事故を未然に防ぐことなんです
ビーチフラッグスは
このライフセービング競技の花形種目の１つで
うつ伏せの状態から素早く起き上がり
助けを求めている人に
駆けつける速さを競うものです
100年を超える歴史を持つ
このビーチフラッグスで
史上最強のチャンピオンと言われているのが
このオーストラリア人の
サイモン・ハリスという選手で
無類の強さを誇っていました
僕は2014年に 彼に勝ち
ライフセービング競技が国技である
オーストラリアの新聞でも紹介されました
僕がこんなにも強いチャンピオンに勝てたのは
沢山の人に助けてもらったからなんです
実は 12年前
18歳の僕は 挫折を経験し
人生のどん底にいました
幼い頃から全てをかけた野球で
「失敗をしてはいけない」という恐れから
身体が硬直してしまい
ボールを投げることが
全くできなくなってしまったんです
僕は本当にどうして良いか
わかりませんでした
そして またこんな気持ちに
なるぐらいだったら
「どうせ自分には何もできない」
そう言い聞かせることで
殻に閉じこもる様になっていったんです
でも本当は
たった一度きりの人生なんだから
自分が輝ける何かを
夢中になれるものを見つけたいな
そんな気持ちも
心から消えることはなかったんです
そんな僕を救ってくれたのが
友達のこんな言葉でした
「きっと大丈夫だよ 失敗してもさ
何度でもやり直せばいいし
人生たった一回なんだから
沢山失敗できれば
その分いろんな経験ができるんじゃない？」
その言葉が 僕の心に
失敗をしてもいいんだっていう
安心を与えてくれたんです
だから僕は
とにかく自分の興味のあるものに
一歩を踏み出してみようと
勇気を振り絞ることができたんだと思います
運動が好きだった僕は
大学入学と同時に
テニスを始めてみたんです
毎日の練習に加え
電車に乗っている時とか
勉強している時とか 授業中とか
ずっとラケットを握って生活していたんです
でも 結果を出すことは出来ませんでした
その後も
サーフィン 総合格闘技 ダブルダッチと
とにかく 自分の興味のあるものに
全力で挑戦してみたんです
でも どれもテニスと同じように
自分にとってこれだ って
言えるものじゃなかったんです
大学も 卒業を迎えようとしていた頃
クラスの友達が アメリカで行われる
スポーツトレーナーを要請するための
短期留学に誘ってくれたんです
そのアメリカの研修で
僕は 世界最先端のトレーニングに
感銘を受けました
そして 帰国後すぐに
スポーツトレーナーになろうと思って
猛勉強を始めたんです
そして その試験を受講するために受けたのが
偶然に 日本ライフセービング協会が主催する
心肺蘇生法の講習会だったんです
そこでこの言葉に出会いました
［あなたは大切な人を
護ることが出来ますか？］
良かったら皆さんも想像してみてください
皆さんは 大切な人が
目の前で苦しんでいる時
その人を護ることが出来ますか？
僕は この時はっとしました
それまで 自分がしたいことを
どうすればいいかずっと考えていたんですけど
誰かを護ろうだなんて
本気で考えたことがあるかと言われたら
なかったんです
僕は その時初めて
ライフセービングという考え方に
感銘を受けました
そして 資格を取得し
ライフセーバーになったんです
その後 ビーチフラッグスの存在を知りました
その時 「これだ！」と思ったんです
瞬発力には自信があったし
何よりも 速く走れば走るほど
護れる命が増えていくんだ
そう考えると 今まで感じたことのない
パワーが沸いてきたんです
でも 社会人になった僕には
とにかく時間がありませんでした
だから 練習場所は
幼いころによく遊んだ
近所の公園の砂場だったんです
（笑）
これ本当です
「あの こんなところで
いったい何をしているんですか？」
「夢を 追いかけています」
（笑）
３回の職務質問にも冷静に対応した僕は
（拍手）
もう ちゃんと説明しました
そして 警官の人もだんだん
応援してくれるようになって
３回目くらいには
その朝 朝早く練習を行ってたんですけど
３年間毎日 スタート練習を行いました
そして 反復回数が10万回を超えた頃
僕は 日本チャンピオンになっていました
（笑）
その時 涙がとめどなく溢れてきたんです
僕 実はこんなに
かっこよく話していますけど
何回も諦めようと思ったんです
でも その時々に支えてくれた人がいて
その人たちのことを思い出しました
僕は 日本チャンピオンになりました
でも 世界最強の王者 サイモン・ハリスに
敵わないことは分かっていたんです
僕は 自分の心に聞いてみました
もしも今 この人生が終わったとしたら
僕は 何に後悔するんだろう？
僕の心は こう動いていました
「オーストラリアに行って
史上最強のチャンピオンに挑戦してみたい」と
26歳の僕は 日本での仕事を退職し
オーストラリアに向かいました
練習初日 行ったはいいんですけど
世界チャンピオンがあまりにも速くて
僕もう愕然としたんですよ
でも 諦めたくなかったんです
だから 自分にとにかくできることに集中して
それを全力でやり続けたんです
するとこれぐらいあった
世界チャンピオンとの差が
ちょっとずつ ほんの少しずつなんですけど
縮まっていったんです
そして ５ヶ月間の練習と研究の結果
僕は あんなに強いチャンピオンに
勝つことが出来ました
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
しかし １週間後に行われた
世界一を決める大会では
銀メダルだったんです
僕のスタートは速かったんですけど
走力で負けちゃったんです
ビーチフラッグスで世界一になるために
走るのが速くなりたい
僕は 日本中の陸上チームに連絡をして
「一緒に練習をさせてください」
そうお願いしました
でも 陸上未経験の僕を受け入れてくれる
チームは一つもなかったんです
人生何度も 思い通りに行かない経験を
積んできた僕は
行き詰まった時こそ シンプルに考える
ということを学んでいました
「ビーチフラッグスで世界一になる為に
誰に教えてもらうのが一番いいんだろう？
そもそも 世界で一番足が速い人って
誰なんだっけ？
あっ　ボルトだ！」
（笑）
でも僕は彼の連絡先を知りませんでした
だから 助けを求めてみたんです
「ビーチフラッグスで
どうしても世界一になりたい
そのためにボルトさんと練習がしたいです
だから 彼の連絡先を知っている人がいたら
教えてください」
そう 思い切って
SNSに投稿してみたんです
すると「ここに連絡してみてください」
そう ボルトさんにつながる連絡先を
教えてくれた人がいたんです
僕は すぐにその連絡先に
どうしても世界一になりたい理由を
一生懸命に送ったんです メールで
すると ジャマイカからすぐに返信が来ました
「わかった すぐに来い
一緒に練習をしよう」と
頭の中の常識では
一見不可能に思えても
動き出せば叶うことがある
本当に嘘みたいなんですけど
僕 ジャマイカで
ボルトさんと練習してきました
（笑）（拍手）
みなさん
そうなんですよ
世界一きついといわれる練習では
毎日世界のトップスプリンターたちが
嘔吐をしながら走っていたんです
そして 遠いアジアの国から来た
陸上未経験の僕のことを
チームメイトたちは
「チャイナ」って呼んでました
僕 日本人なんですけど
でも僕は 前を向き続けました
タイムは断トツで遅かったです
陸上をやったことないんで
でも 誰よりも本気で走り続けたんです
すると チームメイトたちの
僕を見る目が変わってきました
名前も「チャイナ」から「ジャパン」
（笑）
そして「ケン」
帰るころには「ブラザー」って
呼ばれていました
（笑）
ボルトさんは 僕を自宅に招待してくれて
ジャークチキンを振舞ってくれながら
本当にいろんな話をしてくれました
本当に優しい人でした
ジャマイカでの期間で
僕の走力は飛躍的に伸びました
でもそれ以上に
自分の考え方や 一歩の踏み出し方一つで
人生は変えていけるということを学んだんです
しかし 日本に帰国した僕は
とても悲しい経験をしました
朝の通勤ラッシュ時 地下鉄のホームに
女性が倒れていたんです
片手には携帯電話を握っていました
その電話の向こうでは この子のお母さんが
「大丈夫？ 大丈夫なの？」
そう 何度もこの子の名前を
泣きながら呼んでたんです
通話時間はなんと 47分間
47分間もの間
ここを通り過ぎた何百人もの人たちは
この子に声をかける余裕すらなかったんです
僕は慌てて救急車を呼びました
そして「今の世の中 何かおかしい」
って思ったんです
だって 日本は経済的にとても豊かで
安全な国ですよね？
でも 自ら命を絶つ人の割合が
世界で６番目に多いと言われています
そして 自分の人生に期待をして
夢に挑戦しようとする子供が
とても少ないと言われています
経済的な豊かさと 心の豊かさは
一致しないということに気づかされたんです
だから僕は
ライフセービングは海辺の活動ですが
海辺だけじゃなくて 社会全体の
ライフセービング活動をしようと思いました
まずは 学校や企業を回って
かつての自分のように
一歩を踏み出せないで苦しんでいる人を
励ませたらという思いで
講演活動を始めました
そして 自分の身を護ることのできる体力と
誰かを護ろうとする心を持った
未来のライフセーバーを育成するため
ライフセービング運動プログラムを作り
全国の小学校や幼稚園に提供しています
僕がこの人生で何度もくじけそうになった時
いつも誰かが
僕のライフセーバーになってくれました
「きっと大丈夫だよ 失敗してもいいからさ
自分の好きなことをやってみようよ」
「苦しいか？
苦しかったら逃げてもいいんだぞ」
「人生に あなたがしなければいけないことは
一つもありません
だから あなたが本当にやりたいことを
心に聞いてみてください」
「今は辛いかもしれないけどさ
人生って辛いことと楽しいこと
ちょうど半分ずつあるらしいぞ」
「僕はいつでもあなたの味方です」
「できる きっとできる」
そんな励ましの言葉があったから
僕は一歩を踏み続けることが出来ました
そして 気づいたことがあるんです
日本一になったとか
何かが出来なかったとか
そういう結果じゃなくて
一生懸命に何かに向かう
その過程で学んだことや
出会ってきた人たちとの絆こそが
僕の人生を豊かにしているんだ
ということです
人が溺れている時
本当に苦しんでいる時
目の前の あなたの助けが必要です
ライフセービングで養った—
事故を未然に防ぐ為に人を思いやる心
この心を 助けを求めている人が沢山いる
今の世の中に広め
支え合い 高め合う未来を
作っていきたいんです
でもそれは
僕一人で出来ることではありません
だから もし共感してくださる方がいたら
仲間になっていただけないでしょうか？
僕は「誰もが誰かのライフセーバーに」という
社会の実現を強く信じ
明日からも全力で走り続けていきます
ありがとうございました
（拍手）